also know what was the initial concept
or structure as you when you when you
initially began writing the script the
initial concept was that you know Jackie
Kennedy has been portrayed in film and
on television many times and probably
thousands of books have been written
about her but I had always felt like she
had never gotten her proper do that she
did it has always been about her beauty
her elegance her sense of style all of
which was true but that like so many
women in history she had always been
sort of pushed to the periphery of the
narrative it had always been about her
relationship to her husband as opposed
to putting her right in the center and
so you know my sort of guiding principle
from the beginning was how do we tell
her story how do we you know take these
familiar events and recast them
completely by centering them around her
experience and so once I started that
doing that it opened up a whole range of
possibility as I wrote and so was it was
the idea always to focus specifically
just on those days those five days yeah
it was it was yeah and the reason was
was because sort of early in my research
process I discovered to my own surprise
even though I had felt like I knew a lot
about them that Jackie Kennedy had
coined this Camelot mythology a week
after the assassination I thought that
the Kennedy administration had always
been referred to as Camelot and I was
shocked when I realized that she had
created that and she had done it in this
interview one week after her husband was
killed and so that we kind of became the
bookends that I wanted to work in
between Natalie did this project come to
you or did you come to the project well
Darrin had sent me the scripts when he
first first I I guess read it and
decided he at first was going to direct
it and then he decided to produce it and
he sent it to me at that point and I
loved the script but obviously it's it's
delicate material and needs to be
handled by the right director and so for
many years they had sort of tried
finding the right person but it was when
Darren called and said you know you have
to watch
Pablo's films I just saw his work at the
Berlin Film Festival and I think he
could be really interesting for for this
film and that was when it sort of had a
new new life I think because it was
clearly a know clearly a person with
great vision and and who would take it
in places that were unexpected mm-hmm
and probably mentioning the the film of
the tour of the White House is a perfect
example of that I think I mean when did
you stumble across that and when did you
when did you start to move it into into
its key place in the structure of the
film well what happens is that a it's
very simple it is this open youtube and
put Jackie Kennedy and it just pop up
and I saw it I like I don't know 50
times I almost memorize it and and I
also realized that in that white house
tour she was not only you know like
showing the white house and doing it
with such a fragility and beauty at the
same time but she was also talking about
a Lincoln's Widow on Lincoln's life and
how he was assassinated and somehow he
would foreshadow what would happen to
her there was like some kind of strange
a map of pain of her own future and he
was also very beautiful because it
opened the doors to us to show for
example the pablo casals concert that
actually happened there and the party
and things that would show some splendor
that i thought it was nice to bring into
the story because i don't know he would
create a beautiful reflection of of what
those days where not just the Dark One's
and also it could bring an interesting
reflection of what's going on today you
know you would use for me even though
I'm not American it's unavoidable to
think about it and because you make the
movie from nowadays you don't you know
you don't travel in time
and yeah it's just I guess it's this
blender that created the proper contrast
so how is that striking a balance not
only between getting the the the emotion
of in the fragility that Pablo was
talking about along with the you know
very technical act of getting every beat
right in every moment exactly the way it
was in the original film well it was it
was great we actually started with that
part we we did the the white house tour
at the beginning of the film and so I
really like Pablo watched it you know I
can't even count the time is just over
and over and over and was listening to
it constantly and was working with a
great dialect coach who helped me with
the dialect and the voice and getting
all of those specific rhythms because
Pablo was wanted to mix the original and
what we filmed we wanted to be pretty
exact so getting all of those like
Cadence's and pauses and the strong like
sort of elongated words and all of the
the sort of things that she did exact
was actually great sort of preparation
for doing the rest of the scenes that
were not you know based on exact
replicas of filmed existing film so it
really got me into the whole voice and
and everything and then we got to play
with all of the emotions even in the
white house door I mean Paulo would
always be like get more excited about
the table this is so excited about the
table and it was true you really saw her
channeling all of her like passion into
something very socially acceptable for a
woman to be passionate about mmm you
know at that time to be like into decor
was a completely acceptable and laudable
feminine pursuit and so she put like all
of her desire into
these objects and there was a beautiful
thing to get to add to the character to
see what she was like before all this
horrible trauma happened her and so
where was the one where was the White
House you know that created and where
were the interiors filmed well we should
in in Paris for 23 days and and we built
the White House in in a studio in in
Paris in Sundanese which is like close
to Paris I mean it's a rebus one to one
and I think that the job that John saw
after the approach is not to be this
magnificent it's very beautiful and then
we shot 10 days in Washington DC we did
the steers and the interview and so yes
Scott where were some of what were some
of the locations in Washington that were
that were used well we shot the road to
nowhere was the highway to nowhere which
we shot for the strip in Dallas where
they drove to the hospital we shot a
cemetery in Baltimore for Arlington
Cemetery and we shot a house outside of
the White House outside the White House
in front of Pennsylvania Avenue and some
of the streets around there for the
procession and then we shot in a house
about an hour and a half outside of DC
for four Hanus as the as the movie
started to to come together that no one
did did you did you feel that the that
the emotional arc that that I mean not
that you're personally putting Jackie
through but that you know by by moving
forward by moving in time that you do
that that was coming together in a way
that made sense and and showed the
emotional trajectory that you had in
mind yeah because I you know I I don't
think that people's emotional
trajectories are sort of linear or in
what you know I think all of us have
fits and starts in terms of our
emotional experiences and we're also all
very complicated people with different
facets to our character and particularly
a public
person like Jackie and so if you're
trying to capture her experience or make
some sort of statement about who she was
as a woman I think it's actually a
mistake to try to simplify that and to
sort of one clean line and so the sort
of mosaic approach I thought it was
always more more authentic and and more
interesting Natalie did you get a chance
to do any research to find out more
about the character that Greta plays and
what their real-life relationship was
like yes first of all Greta Gerwig is my
favorite person she's she's the greatest
she's an incredible actress as you know
and she's like the person you just want
to be next to and Pablo actually cast
her not realizing that we had already
worked together and we're friends which
was kind of miracle because with we
didn't rehearse at all so and these
characters have such a history that we
had that because we are friends already
and it was very lucky because it was you
know when she hugs me it's my friend
holding me and it's very moving in a
different in a different way
and in terms of the character it was it
was really important I think Noah did an
incredible job choosing which which
people in Jackie's life we would
experience her through because you see
her in these different relationships and
that's sort of how you get to know her
and Nancy was someone that she had been
in kindergarten with and then later in
finishing school with and there was like
a thing about when they've had in their
yearbooks
it sounds like where are you most likely
to be found and Nancy's was laughing
with Jackie and Jackie's with Nancy
laughing with tucky which was her
nickname for Nancy and and it's nice
because I think at that moment of the
assassination it's really an identity
crisis too for Jackie because when she
identifies herself as her husband's wife
and then her husband's gone and she
doesn't even know what's my name anymore
and
there's this person there who knew her
before before she was married and gets
to remind her who she is and and reminds
her that she's not just her husband's
wife she's also the girl who snuck off
and smoke cigarettes in the bathroom and
was like you know flirting with all the
boys and but she she still has that in
her is Paul is it fair to say that this
is the first film of yours that is
really told from a female perspective
with the main main female character and
did that change the way that you you
made the film and approached it yes very
much
I have to say I remember I it was very
scary at the beginning and I what did
Natalie do to scare you no no it's just
mystified by this question cuz I'm like
why is it harder to imagine like a
woman's interior life than like a killer
I can make a movie about like a murderer
and no one's like [ __ ] how did you get
into her head get into his head and okay
so so what I did is like I called my
mother okay
yes they said that's an American
director and like who wants me to make
this film and and she's like who is that
guy I said Darren Aronofsky she made
this movie with this cute dancer yes
right yes ma'am that's the person and
she's like you go and make that movie
saying and I'm like why because that's
the story that we can all relate to and
then we start talking to and discover
that it was you know the story of this
woman who sort of create created an
incredible reflection even to a woman
that it was my mother was born in 1949
in Santiago in Chile
and I was very moved by that and I sort
of understood that that that she was
that Jackie creates something that gave
strength to a lot of people in the world
and he was it was interesting and it was
very scary to try to go and inside a
woman's head terrifying it's a very
brave man please join me in thanking the
filmmakers of Jackie
[Applause]